We have multiple
lengths of time here,
and they're measured in minutes.
So what we want to
do is say, well,
what's an equivalent
number of seconds?
And so the first one is
pretty straightforward.
1 minute is equal to 60 seconds.
By definition, a second
is 1/60 of a minute.
But what about 5 minutes?
Well, we could try
to visualize that.
If 1 minute-- so let's say
that is 1 minute-- if that
is equal to 60 seconds,
then 5 minutes--
let's just make
five copies of this.
So that's 1, 2, minutes,
3, minutes, 4 minutes,
and then 5 minutes.
So you see that 5 minutes
would be 5 times 60 seconds.
And 5 times 60 is 300.
So here you have
so this is going
to be 5 times 60, which
is equal to 300 seconds.
So what about 10 minutes?
Well, same idea.
10 times 60 is 600 seconds.
And what about 60 minutes?
Well, 60 minutes or 60 seconds
per minute times 60 minutes
is equal to 3,600 seconds.
So that's interesting.
Let's take things a
little bit further other.
Let's convert between
hours, minutes, and seconds.
So let's start
off with something
that's a little bit
more straightforward.
Let's say that we have 1 hour.
Well, we know by definition 1
hour is equal to 60 minutes.
And how many seconds
is 60 minutes equal to?
Well, we just figured that out.
60 minutes times 60
seconds per minute
gets us to 3,600 seconds.
Now, what about 2 hours?
Well, it would be
the same exact idea.
60 minutes per hour,
if I have 2 hours,
it's going to be 2 times 60.
2 hours times 60 minutes
per hour gets us to 120.
Well, how many seconds
is that going to be?
Well, there's a couple of
ways you could think about it.
You could take 120 minutes
times 60 seconds per minute.
Or you could say 2 hours
times 3,600 seconds per hour.
So let's do it that way.
So two 2 times 3,600 seconds per
hour gets us to 7,200 seconds.
Now, what if we were
to say 10 hours?
Well, once again, 10
times 60, 10 hours
times 60 minutes per hour
would get us to 600 minutes.
And if we want to think
in terms of seconds,
10 hours times 3,600 seconds
per hour gets us to-- well,
it's going to be
3,600 tens, which
would be 36,000, or 10 times
36 hundred, or 10 times 3,600.